uh so we started the company with the
realization that uh drones are this very
innovative way of capturing data
uh and the way we look at drones is that
they are a sophisticated robot
that we can send to different places
with sensors on it the most minimal
sensor would be a camera
and we can capture data
and if we bring that data and we
analyze it and process it we can
actually deliver a lot of interesting
insights to different industries
[Music]
for 20 minutes i'll be diving into a new
world hopefully something i know nothing
about a new company a new category a new
leader it's time to get curious join me
as i learn from the leaders of today
20 minute leaders is a proud supporter
of make-a-wish israel and tech to peace
and is in proud collaboration with
secret court adventures j ventures
fusion riverside fm birthright excel j
impact leap google for startups and
hippo and in media partnership with ctec
welcome to 20 minute leaders today i am
being joined by jave galer yariv is the
ceo and co-founder of beehive and brings
years of expertise in developing markets
for innovative products technology
strategy and execution
gillard was previously the chief
marketing officer of palm verse a large
it corporation for the telecom industry
before that geller managed marketing and
business development of polycromics
acquired by thermal fissure scientific a
technology startup in the domain of
advanced material sensing before that he
was a team leader at poc consulting
management strategy marketing and
business development for tech startups
and corporations
gilroy holds degrees in physics and
business administration from tel aviv
university and from the massachusetts
institute of technology mit
welcome to 20 minute leaders thank you
so much for being here how are you
hi michael i'm doing great thanks for
having me
thank you very very much a pleasure for
me to learn from your experience uh in
20 short minutes talking a little bit
about drones and about your own career
journey previously marketing at converse
and the variety of other
really really interesting positions and
today the ceo and co-founder of the hype
looking at autonomous drones and the way
that they can help businesses and do
things that they were never able to do
before so thank you very much for being
here tell me a little bit about you know
yourself what do you do why you love it
so much
sure so um
at first um
i'm a self-proclaimed tech geek so i
love technology and so my definition of
what is cool at the end of the day has
to do with uh
dealing with uh uh technology and
innovative technology
uh i
as you mentioned i uh i previously uh
ran uh marketing and strategy at uh at
converse which is a large software i.t
infrastructure company
so we built a lot of uh infrastructure
for the telecom industry including
billing systems and messaging systems
um
quite frankly those were not the sexiest
domains um
uh yeah i.t infrastructure and you're
mainly speaking about what you could do
with it in other cases what it enables
but it wasn't really the thing itself
um one of the things i promised myself
at some point the next i'm gonna do is
going to be highly innovative in a new
industry
uh it should be cool and fun for me
um and also i was looking for something
that has a bit of a tangible feel to it
something that um
uh you can sometimes touch and feel and
see
and not just imagine and uh talk about
so you were so kind
obviously i t solutions those types of
companies they make a tremendous impact
by virtue of the sort of associative
transitive property that the
organizations you're implemented with
they make they but you wanted to be sort
of that end user that actually gets to
touch the field and to experience it
yourself
yeah absolutely and sorry i'm not
belittling it infrastructure we all live
on it of course of course yeah
um
so yes i i was looking for that thing
and i think um
uh when i started via together with my
co-founder uh tomil danielle who's the
company's uh cto and cpo
um we really love this concept of uh
connecting the digital with the physical
world
and that kind of lends itself into some
of that uh taking innovation which a lot
of this is happening today in the uh
digital domain but bringing it to the
physical domain uh so
that kind of all
together with the rise of uh drones
happening as a new innovative idea
uh led to the formation of v hive
so we started the company with the
realization that uh drones are this very
innovative way of capturing data
uh and the way we look at drones is that
they are a sophisticated robot
that we can send to different places
with sensors on it the most minimal
sensor would be a camera
and we can capture data
and if we bring that data and we
analyze it and process it we can
actually deliver a lot of interesting
insights to different industries and
this is kind of what brought via the
concept and idea of uh vs together so if
we're looking at the tangible world
today you know obvi obviously i think
most people still don't go out to the to
the world and look up and see drones
doing various tasks that you know that
we do you know we expect them to do
what are some examples of ways drones
could integrate sort of human computer
interaction
digitizing the physical world
right so quite frankly uh
there are numerous uh cases and i think
the first uh kind of split is if you
look at drones working as part of the
consumer world and we've seen a lot of
discussion around the delivery and and
uh obviously we see people using drones
just for as a recreational tool or a
flying camera which is in itself pretty
cool
um
we're kind of more focused on
enterprises that are using drones and
actually even there there are quite a
lot of verticals that can benefit from
uh drones uh and
when we started out we we uh uh through
a pretty uh a broad net to
try out a lot of different things
um and interestingly one of the uh first
cool use cases was we were approached by
a
large telecom company
that has uh uh tens of thousands of uh
cellular communication towers
and they told us
you know how we get information on
towers today
we have teams of tower climbers these
are people with ropes and harnesses and
hard hats
and they need to drive out and visit a
site and they will
climb on top of the very tall tower
and they will use
different
measurement tools or a
camera tool cameras to snap images
and they
will send a pack of information that
they captured in the field back to
someone in the office so it's it's a
pretty dangerous task and it actually
generates uh fairly sparse information
and in many cases they have to be sent
again to check another thing
and they told us that
this was a big
dangerous and challenging task for them
we were looking for methods of uh
actually doing this in a much more
efficient uh safe
uh cost-effective and rich way
and drones were actually an excellent
solution for for doing that so take me
back to noticing the the fact that
people are climbing
on these tall buildings to take these
measurements and that it's dangerous and
go ahead yeah
so so again it's it's a it's a costly uh
lengthy
and dangerous task and they were looking
for innovative ways to improve that
process so
they asked this could have drone me
potentially a tool for us to do this and
we said absolutely and
so what we provided them was with a
solution that enables them to
take a very low cost simple drone that
he can bind a local store
uh the vive software will
pilot the drone basically will tell the
drone where it needs to go where it
needs to visit what kind of information
it needs to capture
uh and with no user intervention so we
have actually a lot of pictures of
people with their hands in their pockets
kind of waiting for the drug to do its
thing or maybe they're doing some other
tasks in the meantime that they need to
do on the site and
once the drone captures everything which
is actually also very quick compared to
anything else it's like 30 minutes to
capture an entire site
um that data gets uploaded to our system
and we create what is being referred to
today as a digital twin it's it's really
a digital copy of the site so i can have
the entire portfolio of all my sites i
can click one of them on the screen
on a map and i can just see it in 3d as
if i'm standing anywhere in the air or
in the ground next to it looking at it
measuring it
and the system actually analyzes the
data and finds all sorts of interesting
things that they're interested in
finding like equipment that's installed
on the side or things that need to be
fixed or addressed on the site
um so this is a
a pretty impressive leap forward for
them in terms of understanding their
assets
so how are you thinking through sort of
generalized versus specialized so how do
we are we transitioning more towards a
world where we have
drones being able to form
generalist tasks that that are easy to
sort of
to is to to take into different domains
or is it more specific drones for
specific tasks because this sounds like
a pretty specific task that needs to be
done in a specific use case
right um
so
the platform itself is very generic in
terms of how it uses drones the first
task is the system has a sense of
what it is that i'm trying to capture
and what it is could be a tower a
building a road
an agricultural
field a crane so
the system doesn't really care what it
is that i'm collecting information on it
knows how to wrap that uh uh
item or acid or object
with what we call a data acquisition
plan so here all the places where drone
needs to visit and capture information
um so the system is very generic in the
sense of saying
this is something that i want to
digitize
let me launch a drone and let the drone
figure out where the system figure out
how to send the drone capture data on it
um the place where
um
things become a little more specific is
more in the use of ai to analyze the
data so different industries have
different requirements of what is
interesting for them
so in the case of a
cell tower companies they're really
interested in
tell me what is the equipment that is
installed and where is it on the tower
so i can understand and put in my
databases information about all the
inventory uh if it's a train company
actually that's another domain that
we're working in
it's helped me understand if there's any
uh cracks or bends or rust
or missing pins
uh that are developing
and therefore i have a safety issue and
i need to treat this crane
um
if it's a building that i'm doing the
facade inspection on
for a wind turbine that i'm surveying
it's its blades
starts to be a little bit of repeating
themes it's finding defects it's finding
problems that need to be addressed and
it's finding different things in the
field that i as an enterprise have a
difficulty in keeping track of and need
to understand
so right yep and so i think that you
know one of the things that you're
touching on here is this idea that we
have
in the sort of these layers that once
you have the sensors and you're able to
collect the information then there's
sort of the software layer where you can
make sense of that information in a
variety of ways and a lot of the times
these sensors are can you know the same
type of information can then be
manipulated in different ways through
software and it sounds like with vhive
you're you're you're providing the
end-to-end approach right you're not
just doing the drones and the sensors
you're also aiming to provide the
software solution and why is that
because it sounds like a two very
different two very difficult
ta you know r d tasks that that require
a lot of focus on each of them so what
is sort of your decision to try and
specialize in both
so actually you're right and when we
started out our focus was and drones
were completely new and we said
okay we need to first help companies
bring data from the field into the
company because that's a pain how do i
actually get the data in
and very quickly uh with the feedback we
got well this is amazing you know we
capture the data in a fraction of the
time and it's very safe compared to
certain people and we now have
a lot of data but then the natural
immediate question that follows that
okay help me now deal with all this data
that you brought me
help me pinpoint what is the insight not
just the pile of data help me sift
through the data and find the really
interesting thing
so this is the the natural evolution of
the data world right data is uh the oil
of the new oil and so on but uh there is
too much of it to
reach decisions
so that was the evolutionary path we
took
and quite frankly
i think there is a lot of benefit for us
in having the end-to-end approach where
we help the company bring the data
every piece of data that's been captured
we know exactly where it was captured
and why it was captured and then doing
the analytics of that uh we can reach uh
pretty impressive results for our
customers
and so you know going a little bit
higher level to sort of your decision to
go into the drone space and you know
you're
looking at the different things that you
can do yourself that you would be
excited about how how did you converge
on on drones as sort of the go to and i
love drones i'm involved with flight
tracks myself and yeah and i absolutely
love the engineering a bit and the
the you know the different incredible
things that they can provide bringing
the physical world to the digital world
tell me about your
sort of your journey to this field sure
so i was kind of looking a lot of
different domains and i knew that i want
to work in a uh
in a new market first of all i wanted to
be able to kind of set the rules in a
new market um
and uh the beauty with drones is that
it's not like you're going into a very
saturated or even a market that has tons
of players and you're
joining a race with a lot of other
players and you're trying to just
differentiate on top of them
um it was really picking a market that
uh
we could set the standard really we
could come and say
uh you know nobody's doing this yet
we're going to explain to the market how
to do this and why to do this so
it's it's both a blessing and a curse
right i mean the curses you're trying to
educate to market um
but the blessing is that you can
uh come to existing processes and you
know really bring tremendous value uh
that is extremely innovative
um i think um
there's uh uh the the aspect that i
mentioned about something very tangible
and connecting the physical with the
digital which uh appeals to me and to
people in the company a lot
um and then when we saw drones it was
like okay this this is uh
we understand enterprise we understand
that they re enterprises that have a lot
of field operations they need data to to
live
um
we can solve this with drones uh and
actually
we decided okay we're gonna do drones
uh
we want these
low-cost off-the-shelf drones it doesn't
have to be some fancy
piece of equipment that we build
especially for a certain task
i can have a customer in australia that
goes to a local store buys a drone the
software will make it do amazing things
hot it needs to be autonomous
because we don't want experts to use it
we want anybody to be able to to operate
a drone right it's a tool for for us
so take a tablet follow instructions
press a button drone takes off and the
system takes care of everything
actually another thing that was really
cool is we said
wait we have these small low-cost drones
there's software that's flying them why
settle for a single drone and actually
one of the very cool things that we do
is we enable you to deploy multiple
drones that are working together as a
high sense the name
that are working in parallel and
capturing data
um well the short answer why
why not do it because it was very
difficult but you know managing a lot of
these uh
uh flying uh devices in the air but uh
that's exactly what we've done
uh so um
it's highly scalable because if i have a
large area that need to cover where a
complex task i can just deploy multiple
drones the system will just break the
work down and send this drone here that
drone there and
make sure that they're not interfering
but actually complementing each other
awesome yeah
i i have so you know
it all sounds really really cool and it
sounds like people you know different
i'm always curious about how different
personas interact with different
industries and it sounds like you're
offering both sort of the physical
hardware software layer with also very
tangible use cases that people can
actually experience in the real world so
you know if you see somebody you know
randomly down the street and you you
want to see whether they'd be this is
this is the right thing for them to do
because most people don't even know
about you know drones and the type of
thing that they that they can do you
know working with drones so how how do
you sort of think through a conversation
like that with a person what what type
of person would be really interested on
working with with the types of things
you do with beehive
uh so are you asking more from a uh our
customers perspective were people who
work at v hive or just in general or
yeah you know any you know engineer
product manager yeah the type of person
that would come to
a company like v hype or the drone
industry and and would love it this is
sort of would be a calling for them yeah
so first of all i think what we do is uh
highly uh uh
interdisciplinary um and that's one of
the things that i love about it is that
um
you know it's not just one thing it's
not it's not just software
it it's really it's really a mix that
involves things like uh
uh
taking the drone and interfacing with it
telling it giving it instructions of
what to do
by using the mobile device in the field
that is connected to a cloud-based
system
uh that has algorithms that will
take a job and break it down to multiple
drones and tell them where they need to
go and where they need to capture so
that's one part of it uh which involves
a lot of things and then
this feeds into
like a
an entire pipeline that takes the data
that the drone is capturing
creates it using uh
creates with it using a technology
called photogrammetry that takes a lot
of images and cross-references them in
3d to create the 3d model
uh so now you have a 3d model a copy of
something physical that you saw uh
earlier outside of the field i now have
it on my screen i can rotate it
manipulate it
so
it's almost uh bringing that elements of
3d gaming uh uh
into uh into the enterprise world
uh i mean the enterprise world has used
cad products and things like that
but the ease of use and the richness and
the photorealism of what that will get
generated really uh
is uh is pretty amazing uh compared to
anything previously
uh and then we bring on top of that a
layer of ai machine learning that looks
at images and 3d models and extracts out
of that
things that our customers are looking
for
so it's it's a very broad stack of uh
capabilities that come together to
deliver something very holistic
sounds sounds awesome i love the
transition from
from the previous journey to the new one
the intentionality behind it finding
this personal excitement the tangibility
aspect i love
the integration from the physical and
the the physical medical world and and
looking at a at a new way in which we
can utilize technology to to interact
with the world around us with different
sensors than we already have and and it
sounds like besides it helping uh create
helping mitigate tasks that that some of
them are actually dangerous you're also
actually providing data that previously
you had no transparency and
observability into and so it definitely
is a strong impact and it sounds like
you truly love what you do so thank you
very very much uh stay safe and stealthy
and and best of luck with beehive thank
you great thanks a lot michael thanks
[Music]
you